founded in 2013 a startup based in
London called canna is built to
do-it-yourself computer kit for kids it
costs $150 and teaches youngsters about
electronics and how to code these three
lovely children agreed to be our DIY
guinea pig and to take a crack at making
a canna well should we let you guys get
to it you want to start building yeah
check it away
is it fun to build your computer instead
of just grabbing an iPad yeah what's fun
about it
oh it teaches you about that why do you
like to cuz I wanted to be an inventor
when I grew up it's a typist the dude
floating around the office is Alex Klein
a co-founder of the company
he's a former journalist who decided to
give up on the most noble profession
imaginable to help kids get their hands
dirty with computing November of 2012 we
were playing around with the Raspberry
Pi you could do so many things with it
at the time developers were sending it
into space they were sending it under
the ocean but we were having trouble
getting started so you want to make a
kit that was simple enough for a kid to
build themselves yeah exactly
this generation they have only
experienced computers in the post jobs
era you know perfectly polished
constrained consumption devices the
notion of counter was to break it apart
and let a young person build a computer
from the inside out what do you think
cycle yeah
for Alex it's all about creating tools
that inspire and encourage creativity
you know they're building apps that are
worth millions you know they're solving
local problems in ways that their elders
could never comprehend if you give them
something that's as powerful as you know
a mainland developer something that can
make a robot something that can make a
server you'll see what this generation
can do they really have the power we
want to make something that does your
cooking cleans up your rooms and fixes
your stuff inside of the children doing
chores that would be amazing with that